A protocol is also a type.
You can use a protocol name in all
of the places you would normally use
any other type.
To describe variables, constants, and
properties, to indicate parameter and
return types, and to indicate
the item types in a collection.
Here's a class called DinnerCrew.
This DinnerCrew is very egalitarian and
inclusive.
All of its members need to implement
the Sous Chef protocol, but
otherwise they could be of any class,
enum, or struct.
So we specify the members
array property like this.
We write Souschef where we would
otherwise write the type of the items in
the array.
And we do the same for
the parameters in the init method.
But Sous Chef is in the class itself or
a struct.
How can it be capable of making dinner?
Sous Chef has no logic of its own.
To specify Sous Chef
as a type is to say,
I don't care what type goes here as
long as it adopts a Sous Chef protocol.
Here, you can see that it doesn't
matter if I initialize a DinnerCrew
with a random passer by or a roommate.
As long as each member implements
the Sous Chef protocol.